l'Occident a choisi de s'endormir
au moment même où la Chine, l'Inde
et le reste de l'Asie se réveillaient.
Pourquoi est-ce arrivé ?
Je suis ici pour répondre à ce grand mystère.
Que veux-je dire par « l'Occident a choisi de s'endormir » ?
Je fais ici référence à l'échec de l'Occident
à réagir de façon intelligente et réfléchie
au contexte d'un nouveau monde qui a clairement été engendré
par le retour de l'Asie.
En tant qu'ami de l'Occident, je m'en inquiète.
Mon objectif aujourd'hui est donc d'essayer d'aider l'Occident.
Mais je dois d'abord commencer l'histoire
en parlant de comment l'Occident a bien réveillé le reste du monde.
Regardez ce premier graphique.
De l'an 1 jusqu'à 1820,
les deux plus grandes économies du monde ont toujours été la Chine et l'Inde.
C'est seulement ces deux siècles derniers que l'Europe a décollé,
suivie par l'Amérique du Nord.
Dans l'histoire du monde, les deux siècles derniers
sont par conséquent une aberration historique majeure.
Toute aberration a naturellement une fin
et c'est que nous observons actuellement.
Si vous regardez ce deuxième graphique,
vous verrez avec quelle rapidité et avec quelle vigueur
la Chine et l'Inde font leur retour.
La grande question est de savoir
qui a réveillé la Chine et l'Inde.
La seule réponse honnête à cette question, c'est que la civilisation occidentale
en est responsable.
L'Occident a été le premier à se moderniser avec succès,
à se transformer.
Au début, il a utilisé son pouvoir pour coloniser et dominer le monde.
Mais avec le temps, il a partagé les dons de la sagesse occidentale
avec le reste du monde.
J'aimerais ajouter ici que j'ai moi-même bénéficié
de ce partage de la sagesse occidentale.
Quand je suis né à Singapour –
qui était alors une colonie britannique pauvre –
en 1948,
j'ai fait l'expérience, comme les trois quarts de l'humanité alors,
de la pauvreté extrême.
D'ailleurs, le premier jour où je suis allé à l'école,
à l'âge de six ans,
on m'a mis dans un programme spécial d'alimentation
car j'étais sous-alimenté dans les faits.
Aujourd'hui, je suis plutôt suralimenté.
(Rires)
Mais le plus grand présent que j'ai reçu a été l'éducation occidentale.
Maintenant que, dans ma vie, je suis passé
de la misère du tiers monde à l'existence confortable de la classe moyenne,
je peux parler avec une intime conviction des effets de la sagesse occidentale
et de son partage avec le monde.
Et un des présents extraordinaires que l'Occident a distribués,
c'est l'art du raisonnement.
Le raisonnement n'a pas été inventé par l'Occident.
Il est inhérent à toutes les cultures et les civilisations.
Amartya Sen a décrit à quel point il est enraciné dans la civilisation indienne.
Pourtant, il ne fait aucun doute
que l'Occident a poussé l'art du raisonnement
à un niveau beaucoup plus élevé.
Et avec la révolution copernicienne,
les Lumières,
la révolution industrielle,
l'Occident a puissamment élevé le raisonnement
et l'a utilisé, ce qui est aussi important :
il l'a mis en application pour résoudre de nombreux problèmes concrets majeurs.
Et l'Occident a alors partagé l'art du raisonnement pratique
avec le reste du monde.
Je peux vous dire que c'est ce qui a mené
à ce que j'appelle trois révolutions silencieuses.
Et en tant qu'Asiatique,
je peux raconter comment ces révolutions silencieuses ont transformé mon continent.
La première révolution s'est produite en économie.
La principale raison pour laquelle tant d'économies asiatiques,
y compris les sociétés communistes de Chine et du Vietnam,
ont connu un développement économique si spectaculaire,
c'est parce qu'ils ont finalement compris, absorbé et mis en place
l'économie de marché –
un cadeau de l'Occident.
Adam Smith avait raison.
Si vous laissez les marchés décider,
la productivité augmente.
Le deuxième présent a été psychologique.
Ici encore, je peux parler de mon expérience personnelle.
Quand j'étais enfant,
ma mère et sa génération croyaient
que leur vie était déterminée par le destin.
On ne pouvait rien y faire.
Ma génération
et la génération suivante d'Asiatiques
croient qu'elles peuvent prendre les choses en main
et améliorer leur vie.
Et cela pourrait expliquer, par exemple,
le pic d'entrepreneuriat que vous observez partout en Asie actuellement.
Et si vous voyagez aujourd'hui en Asie,
vous verrez également les effets de la troisième révolution :
celle de la bonne gouvernance.
Grâce à la bonne gouvernance –
voyagez en Asie,
vous verrez un meilleur système de santé,
un meilleur enseignement,
de meilleures infrastructures,
de meilleures politiques publiques.
C'est un monde différent.
Après avoir transformé le monde
en partageant sa sagesse avec le reste du monde,
la réaction logique et rationnelle de l'Occident aurait dû être
de se dire : « Nous devons nous ajuster et nous adapter à ce nouveau monde. »
Au lieu de cela, l'Occident a choisi de s'endormir.
Pourquoi est-ce arrivé ?
Je crois que cela s'est produit
car l'Occident a été distrait par deux événements majeurs.
Le premier événement a été la fin de la guerre froide.
Oui, la fin de la guerre froide a été une grande victoire.
L'Occident a défait la puissante Union soviétique sans tirer un coup de feu.
Incroyable.
Mais remporter une grande victoire de la sorte,
c'est aussi la porte ouverte à l'arrogance et à un orgueil démesuré.
Et cet orgueil démesuré a été très bien saisi par le très célèbre essai
de Francis Fukuyama :
« La Fin de l'histoire ».
Fukuyama a fait passer un message très élaboré,
mais tout ce que l'Occident a retenu de cet essai,
c'était que nous, les démocraties libérales,
avions gagné,
nous ne devions pas changer,
ni nous adapter,
c'est le reste du monde qui devait changer et s'adapter.
Malheureusement, à la manière d'un dangereux opiacé,
cet essai a beaucoup endommagé les cerveaux en Occident
car il les a endormis
au moment même où la Chine et l'Inde se réveillaient
et l'Occident ne s'y est ni ajusté ni adapté.
Le second événement majeur a été le 11 septembre,
qui a eu lieu en 2001.
Comme nous le savons, le 11 septembre a choqué et a causé beaucoup de douleur.
J'ai moi-même ressenti ce choc et cette douleur
car j'étais à Manhattan le jour du 11 septembre.
Le 11 septembre a aussi produit beaucoup de colère
et, pris dans cette colère, les États-Unis ont décidé d'envahir l'Afghanistan
et plus tard l'Irak.
Hélas,
en partie à cause de cette colère,
l'Occident n'a pas remarqué l'importance d'un autre événement
qui s'est aussi produit en 2001.
La Chine a rejoint l'Organisation mondiale du commerce.
Quand on intègre soudainement
900 millions de nouveaux ouvriers
dans le système capitaliste mondial,
cela conduit naturellement
à ce que l'économiste Joseph Schumpeter a appelé la destruction créative.
Les ouvriers occidentaux ont perdu leur travail,
ils ont vu leur revenu stagner,
il était clair qu'il fallait penser à de nouvelles stratégies concurrentielles,
que les ouvriers se reconvertissent,
qu'ils acquièrent de nouvelles compétences.
Rien de tout cela n'a été fait.
C'est en partie pour cette raison
que les États-Unis sont devenus
la seule grande économie développée
où le revenu moyen des 50% moins bien payés –
oui, 50 % –
a baissé sur une période de 30 ans,
de 1980 à 2010.
C'est en partie pour cette raison
que nous en sommes arrivés à l'élection de Donald Trump en 2016,
lui qui a utilisé la colère de la classe ouvrière,
majoritairement blanche.
C'est ce qui a aussi contribué à la montée du populisme en Europe.
Et on se demande
si le populisme aurait pu être évité
si le 11 septembre et la fin de la guerre froide n'avaient pas distrait l'Occident ?
Mais voici la grande question face à nous aujourd'hui :
est-il trop tard ?
L'Occident a-t-il déjà perdu ?
Et ma réponse est qu'il n'est pas trop tard.
L'Occident est en mesure de s'en remettre
et de faire un retour en force.
Et, en utilisant l'art occidental du raisonnement,
je recommanderais à l'Occident d'adopter une nouvelle stratégie 3M :
minimaliste, multilatérale et machiavélique.
(Rires)
Pourquoi minimaliste ?
Même si la domination occidentale a pris fin,
l'Occident continue d'intervenir et d'interférer dans les affaires
de beaucoup d'autres sociétés.
C'est imprudent.
Cela crée de la colère et de la rancœur,
notamment dans les sociétés musulmanes.
Cela épuise également les ressources et les esprits des sociétés occidentales.
Je sais que le monde musulman
rencontre des difficultés à se moderniser.
Il devra trouver sa voie,
mais il y arrivera mieux si on le laisse faire seul.
Je peux le dire avec conviction, car je viens d'une région,
l'Asie du Sud-Est,
qui abrite presque autant de musulmans que le monde arabe.
266 millions de musulmans.
L'Asie du Sud-Est est l'une des régions du monde avec le plus de diversité,
car elle compte également 146 millions de chrétiens,
149 millions de bouddhistes –
du grand véhicule et du petit véhicule –
ainsi que des millions de taoïstes, de confucianistes, d'hindous
et même de communistes.
Jadis appelée « les Balkans de l'Asie »,
l'Asie du Sud-Est devrait connaître actuellement un choc de civilisations.
Au lieu de cela, on observe que l'Asie du Sud-Est
est l'une des régions les plus pacifiques et prospères au monde
dotée de la deuxième organisation régionale la plus aboutie :
l'ASEAN.
Donc clairement, le minimalisme fonctionne.
L'Occident devrait l'essayer.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais je sais aussi que le minimalisme ne peut pas résoudre tous les problèmes.
Il y a des problèmes qu'il faut affronter :
Al-Qaïda, l’État islamique –
ils restent des dangers menaçants.
Ils doivent être débusqués, ils doivent être détruits.
La question est la suivante : est-il préférable que l'Occident,
qui représente 12% de la population mondiale –
oui, 12% –
lutte seul contre ces menaces
ou avec l'aide des 88% restants d'habitants de la planète ?
La réponse logique et rationnelle est
qu'il faudrait y œuvrer avec les 88% restants.
Où faut-il se rendre
si on veut obtenir le soutien de l'humanité ?
Il n'y a qu'un seul endroit :
les Nations Unies.
J'ai été ambassadeur aux Nations Unies deux fois.
Peut-être que cela me rend un peu biaisé,
mais je peux vous dire que travailler avec l'ONU peut mener au succès.
Pourquoi la première guerre du Golfe,
menée par le président George H. W. Bush,
a-t-elle réussi ?
Alors que la deuxième guerre du Golfe,
menée par son fils, le président George W. Bush,
a échoué ?
L'une des principales raisons, c'est que Bush père s'est adressé à l'ONU
pour obtenir le soutien de la communauté mondiale
avant de déclarer la guerre à l'Irak.
Donc, le multilatéralisme fonctionne.
Une autre raison pour laquelle nous devons travailler avec l'ONU,
c'est que le monde se rétrécit.
Nous devenons un petit village mondial interconnecté.
Tous les villages ont besoin d'un conseil municipal.
Et le seul conseil municipal mondial que nous avons,
comme le disait Kofi Annan, feu secrétaire général de l'ONU,
c'est l'ONU.
En tant qu'analyste géopolitique,
je sais qu'on est souvent taxé de naïveté
quand on travaille avec l'ONU.
Laissez-moi donc introduire ici mon point de vue machiavélique.
Machiavel est une figure qu'on tourne souvent en dérision en Occident,
mais le philosophe libéral Isaiah Berlin nous a rappelé
que le but de Machiavel était de promouvoir la vertu, pas le mal.
Quel est mon point de vue machiavélique ?
Le voici : quelle est la meilleure façon pour l'Occident
de contenir les nouvelles puissances
qui émergent ?
La réponse est que la meilleure façon d'y arriver
passe par des règles et des normes multilatérales,
des institutions multilatérales
et des procédures multilatérales.
Laissez-moi conclure par un dernier grand message.
En tant qu'ami de longue date de l'Occident,
je suis très conscient du pessimisme qui a envahi les sociétés occidentales.
Beaucoup en Occident ne croient pas qu'un grand avenir les attend,
que leurs enfants auront une vie meilleure.
S'il vous plaît, ne craignez pas l'avenir ou le reste du monde.
Je peux le dire avec conviction,
car en tant qu'hindou originaire du Sind,
je ressens un lien culturel direct
avec des cultures très diverses
de sociétés allant de Téhéran à Tokyo.
Plus de la moitié de l'humanité vit dans cet espace.
Ainsi, grâce à ce lien culturel direct,
je peux vous dire avec force conviction
que si l'Occident choisit d'adopter une stratégie plus intelligente,
minimaliste, multilatérale et machiavélique,
le reste du monde sera heureux de collaborer avec l'Occident.
Un grand avenir attend l'humanité.
Embrassons-le tous ensemble.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)